let's discuss the solution to our latest Amdahl's law
quiz. We have three possible improvements and now we
can use Amdahl's law to tell us which one
of them is the best. For improving the branch
CPI this is our option 1: the overall speedup
is branches are happening 20% of the time, so,
so this is actually the percentage of time so
we can apply Amdahl's law properly. So the unaffected execution
time is 80% and the 20% we do affect, we speedup by how much?
By factor of 4 over 3, so this is 1.33. And we get
an overall speedup of 1.05. The clock
frequency increase from 2 to 2.3 gigahertz,
is affecting all the execution time, so we can just compute the speedup of
this, but for the sake of exercise, let's apply Amdahl's law. One minus
fraction enhanced is 0, because everything is enhanced. The fraction
enhanced is 1, and the speedup we get here, by going
from 2 to 2.3 gigahertz, is 2.3 over 2; which is
1.15 and the overall speedup we get is the 1.15.
The third option is for stores, the unaffected fraction is at 0.9, the affected
fraction is 0.1. The speedup of going from 3 to 2 is 1.5, and when
we compute that we get 1.034. So it's a very small speedup. Even smaller
than we got for branches. So overall
improving the clock frequency gives us a significantly
higher improvement overall, than the other
two options. Primarily because this is a
smaller improvement in terms of speedup on the fraction affected. But the clock
frequency increase affects all of the
instructions, versus here, we affect only 20%
of the execution time and here we're affecting only 10% of the execution time.